all right who is your celebrity look
like
um i've been told my celebrity lookalike
is rihanna
and also zendaya
my celebrity lookalike is mark wahlberg
you get it a lot um usually about once a
month
lma
[Music]
drake
i've gotten kylie jenner from some
makeup artist but from mac and then the
wendy's girl because of the
the pigtails so that's about it
my celebrity lookalike is robin thicke
because
i've been told by multiple people i take
it as a compliment
cat from euphoria
a lot of people say i look like rosie
o'donnell
or a very like kind of middle-aged uh
queen victoria
but i would say rosie more
my celebrity lookalike is eva mendez
apparently justin timberlake do you
agree with it
um um i'll take it as a compliment but
it's hard it's hard yeah yeah
i like it i like it it's a good one
gabrielle union
um archie from riverdale do you agree
i've never seen the show some people
come up oh my gosh you look just like
him other people are like
like my girlfriend said i don't look
anything like them
selena gomez
from the movie up russell i agree with
it he's got a good smile
i guess i'd say like young j-lo okay
it's a really big compliment but i guess
i'd say i look like her
the rock they call me the pebble
[Laughter]
people say look like meredith from brave
dj scheme and a bad bunny
i haven't gotten very many but only
robbie from victorious do you agree with
it
i think it's just the hair pretty much i
look like sean pan
i don't know if it's true but people say
i look like miguel
my celebrity lookalike is vanessa hedges
uh paris jackson
[Music]
uh definitely i've been uh giving a
thorough thought and
that guy right there with his
rolling paper he's definitely my uh
look-alike celebrity and quite a
celebrity
did you just see that right now as i was
asking that
uh i have thought before that i look
like him but this is like a torah
coincidence
jane from descendants i get that a lot
i've been told since i was a kid that i
look like andre agassi
especially without the hair
brook from one tree health
i guess i would say ed sheeran ed
sheeran everyone thinks i look like ed
sheeran just because we share the same
hair color
so you don't agree that you look like
him at all i don't think so but everyone
else does
winona writer
uh lit from shameless
i've been told i look like raven simone
and maya rudolph
arsenio hall
in high school i told i was told that i
looked like ashley green who was the
actress who played alice from twilight i
actually got my hair cut to look like
her from the very first movie and
throughout the rest of the movies
and actually they dedicated a yearbook
page to me
and all of the other girls in my high
school that looked like celebrity
look-alikes and it was because of
my hair and how i looked so my celebrity
lookalike is jared follow will
he's the bassist of kings of leon
um i've gotten many times that people
think i look like haley steinfeld
i don't know i don't see it but hey
i'll take it she's amazing people be
telling me i look like t.i
people say that i look like kirsten
dunst
and cameron diaz
i don't know if i have a celebrity
look-alike but i've been told that
i look like i would be killed off
immediately on a cw show
do you agree i mean i guess i can see it
i don't
yeah i guess so i guess so
cool thanks who does your celebrity look
like oh amanda peace
is my celebrity look alike
you know i've had a lot of ladies say i
look like leo dicaprio over the years
you know but
i don't know but it's good you know he's
he's not bad could be could be a lot
worse
allegedly britney snow
who's your celebrity look-alike
okay everyone tells me i look like
scarlett johansson
stone cold steve austin can i get a hell
yeah
alicia silverstone
spike lee you said i look like spike lee
you get it a lot
yeah do you agree
except for he probably wouldn't be
wearing a lakers hat probably
princess jasmine
i'm dylan from 13 reasons why
so i've been told that my celebrity
parents would be
matt dillon and miranda carr
i've been told that i look like usher
personally i get that all the time
especially when i'm traveling around so
that's mine i guess
edna mode because of the hair and the
glasses
a lot of people tell me that i look like
paris hilton but i've also gotten
lindsay lohan
and kimberly kardashian do you agree
with any of them
um probably kim
so i get angelina jolie and charlize
theron do you agree with any of them
i'm only with the lips and they're
natural by the way
brody jenner i get rashida jones a lot
from the office or from parks and rec
dan levy
alicia keys maybe a little mariah carey
but probably closer to alicia key i got
chris
tucker and todd bridges
from different strokes so
it's a little bit everything we all the
same though
hey everyone quick announcement i
decided to make a separate channel for
my podcast
it's gonna be linked in the description
the new channel is called hey stranger
which as you know is the name of my
podcast
if you enjoy watching the video versions
to my podcast make sure to subscribe on
there
that would mean a lot and then of course
you could still find the audio versions
of my podcast on all the podcast
platforms
and yeah that's pretty much it thank you
guys for everything
i love you all i'm happy to be back and
i'll see you next week